justement cette question du futur péage
sur le pont champlain battu bros bonsoir
à vous quelqu'un dans le reportage
parlait d'utilisateur payeur c'est
exactement le point une vue minoritaire
ou le point de vue des conservateurs oui
c'est cet argument là utilisateur-payeur
effectivement c'est le point de vue
minoritaires et oui c'est l'argument
favori un peu de ceux qui s'opposent qui
son bec et on milite pour cette
instauration à péage évidemment les
conservateurs utilisateur-payeur ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire aller chercher
l'argent pour construire ce futur pont
dans les poches de ceux qui vont
l'utiliser ce pont qui vont l'utiliser
dès décembre 2018 mais oui les
conservateurs sur son sursaut ce modèle
là mais ils ne sont pas seuls à militer
pour pour un péage on va entendre
brièvement denis lebel est son leitmotiv
qui le rappelle depuis depuis deux ans
mais aussi elizabeth may qu'on peut
ranger un peu dans le même quand on
écoute depuis le début nom d'ipad berges
poitevin façon c'est pour nous une
question de négociation parce que je ne
veux pas prendre imposition axé mon
président
alors on a vu elizabeth may lancer un
petit regard sur le côté sur le côté
c'est son chef adjoint elle était
entourée aussi denis coderre pourquoi
parce qu'elle sent qu'il n'est pas
complètement fermes sur cette question
là nous ont décidé de l'inclure dans
ceux qui sont pour le péage parce que
les verts leur argument c'est dire qu'un
péage ça réduit le trafic et donc ça
réduit la pollution sur ce point là cet
argument de la réduction du trafic et de
la congestion
jean-sébastien en parler un petit peu
puis il ya des études qui ont été faites
notamment une étude du mtq qui a été
révélée par un radio canada l'année
dernière il avait fait deux scénarios
sur le coût d'un péage coût à 3 $ par
passage secret 6000 véhicules qui irait
sur les autres ponts de la région
notamment le pont victoria coup à cinq
dollars 72 mille véhicules de plus donc
congestion supplémentaires et autant de
pollution
si on pose la question ouvertement
faut-il instaurer un péage sur le futur
pont champlain
et bien il y en a deux qui sont pour
l'un farouchement le parti conservateur
l'autre plus timidement le parti vert et
voilà l es trois autres passes est assez
clair sans crainte
les trois autres sont sans eau sans
corps entrelacés le camp du non npd
libéraux le blog
on va écouter leur tombe sur cette
question là parce que les quelques
nuances notamment pour les libéraux un
péage nouveau sur le pont champlain pour
le npd
il n'en est pas question on est content
un péage sur le pont champlain le
gouvernement libéral que je formerai
après le 19 octobre à n'imposera pas de
péage sur le pont champlain et je peux
le dire maintenant
alors voilà il dit le précise je peux le
dire maintenant pourquoi il dit ça parce
que justin trudeau n'a pas été tout le
temps totalement ferme toujours sur
cette question pendant des mois il
tergiversait un peu il attendait de voir
le cas financiers commencent à être
financés maintenant ça y est c'est une
promesse de campagne une promesse qu'il
a faite notamment aux maires à denis
coderre dont théoriquement il n'est pas
censé revenir dessus
petit bilan alors pour cette question
pour ces trois parties la faut-il
instaurer un péage sur le pont champlain
c'est non pour les libéraux le npd et
pour le bloc québécois
petit aparté sur cette image qu'on voit
dans la vidéo de promotion du nouveau
pont on voit ici ça ressemble quand même
de très près à un dispositif de péage
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer si
jamais le parti qui vient au pouvoir
décide d'abolir cette idée th c'était
dans le cahier des charges qui a été
acceptée par snc lavalin et bien ces
infrastructures canada qui nous a donné
la confirmation
on pourra tout simplement retiré cette
donnée-là du péage du futur partenariat
donc le partenariat subsiste le péage
disparaît donc les partis qui milite
contre
théoriquement on la fois ouverte ce sont
des images et web en 1990 est trop jeune
mais on s'en souvient j'étais trop jeune
mais voilà ça ressemblera pas à ça si
jamais il ya un péage ça c'était avant
sur le pont champlain comme le pain
arrivant là 25 par transpondeur très
bien mathieu merci beaucoup aux
prochaines en jeu dans quelques jours on
verra